and tonight there's finally an arrest
and that brutal attack on a conservative
volunteer on the campus of UC Berkeley
February 19th Hayden Williams went to
recruit conservative students and this
was the response well it took police 10
days to arrest this man who's clearly
identifiable to anyone who knows him
28-year old Zachary Greenberg faces
assault and battery charges here now for
an Ingram angle exclusive is that victim
Hayden Williams and his attorney Harmeet
Dillon Hayden how you doing I've been
better but I'm covering it all right
yeah you can look at me that's all right
I'll do a lot of TV we really appreciate
your joining us by the way I hearing
that punch to the face I mean anyone
who's been punched in the face like
whether you were a little kid or an
adult it hurts
you think why'd it take so long to find
this guy well I think due process was
being followed which I appreciate that
as a constitutional conservative myself
but you know I'm grateful that the
police did their job and found this guy
but I'm reminded with UC Berkeley and
the fact that they allowed such a
culture of intolerance and violence
toward conservative viewpoints to grow
at Berkeley and he didn't even thrive
really I think it's a it was an attempt
to say don't try this again har mate
you've represented a lot of people
who've been treated terribly just for
their viewpoints exactly so and what's
the next step here well the next step is
that now that he's been arrested the
facts and the investigation get turned
over to the prosecutor's office in
Alameda County and they will decide what
charges to bring we've been told and the
bail is set for one count of a felony
assault with great bodily harm as you
can see Hayden is still got a bruise on
his face almost two weeks after the fact
now in previous incidents of great
bodily harm assaults on the campus these
incidents have usually been pled out and
the felony charges are often dismissed
to a misdemeanor and no time is served
so that's gonna be my concern right now
is to make sure that this is treated
with the seriousness are you gonna file
a lawsuit a civil suit against this guy
well the civil suit usually trails we
want to get in the way of the criminal
process and so I think that's really
number one but number two he appears to
be somebody who has a history at UC
Berkeley somebody who is
worked for the campus for a period of
months and also audited classes there
and as Hayden said it is common for
these anti-fatigue thugs and people who
don't look like aunt Eva like this guy
to float around menace people throw
punches my clients who are UC Berkeley
undergrads they all have experienced as
many times
Hayden is this gonna stop you from being
involved in conservative politics on
campus or off no this is only serving to
embolden me and and reinforce the the
idea that Leadership Institute and
campus reform that their mission is as
important now as ever
well maybe take a little Tai kwon doe to
you get hit in the face you know I mean
it's a that's why it's like twice the
size of Hayden and and and you know 10
years ago like a little roundhouse kick
to the side of the head but it's meant
to intimidate this is meant to tell any
conservative across camp across the
country don't try this again cuz what
happened to this young man is gonna
happen to you imagine if it's a young
woman that's right who wanted to be on
campus that's right
thank you for being here we really
really appreciate it and I'm glad you're
okay thanks Randy